the Senate Judiciary Committee's
confirmation hearing for Supreme Court
nominee Brett Kavanaugh began minutes
ago with a noisy protest angry Democrats
on the committee called for delay to
give senators more time to read newly
released documents the committee
received just last night less than 15
hours ago there's 4,000 pages of
documents that we have not had an
opportunity to review
this committee sir is a violation of
even the values I've heard he talked
about time and time again the ideals
that we should have what is the rush Jan
Crawford is on Capitol Hill where
committee members will question
Cavanaugh this week about his views on a
wide range of issues Jan good morning
well I mean this was pretty
extraordinary what we saw to start this
hearing chairman chuck Grassley barely
gotten a few words of welcome out before
you started hearing protesters from the
audience and then those Senate Democrats
who are on this committee one by one
start to call for this hearing to be
adjourned
now their argument here as a process
when they're saying they haven't got
enough access to the documents late last
night there are about 40,000 pages of
documents released but the Republicans
and chairman Grassley continued to say
today that they've gotten more than
400,000 pages of Judge Cavanaugh's
documents over the past couple months so
they have more than enough information
from his time in the Bush White House in
addition to his 12 years of service on
the federal appeals court so the
Republicans are really rejecting the
argument that the Democrats are trying
to make that they just haven't had time
to review this judge's records now of
course as this hearing is under way
you're going to hear opening statements
from all of these committee members
today and then later on today judge
Kavanagh will make his opening statement
we saw him ask this hearing finally
quieted down and protestors were removed
we saw him introduce his family to the
committee and then later today he will
talk about his life his judicial
influences and how he is vowing to
remain impartial and independent as a
justice if confirmed to the United
States Supreme Court Jan thank you